okay what's up everyone I'm Beauty pie
up floor gang if your ceiling gang get
that flip out of here let's dig into the
memes oh my god oh my god what is
happening the floor again boys okay fine
so may the second version okay this is
the top rated one oh it's so small also
out of the bulge nice now this is what
actually happened because people keep
using these photos in case your ceiling
anger you're new here to reference that
I'm short that's just a running joke on
this channel I'm not short I'm extremely
tall and very comfortable about my
height I feel very large at all times
thank you this is actually
behind-the-scenes footage they were like
sorry Felix we don't have any we don't
have any chairs and I was like don't
worry fam I got you
I don't normally do this but I let you
sit but wait there's more oh my god
rhett and Link skipping out on cabs are
you skipping out of leg day courage Oh
God
without that pathetic Breton link I'm
sorry the secret is out we have more
than once
evidence oh look there's more there's
more it never stopped
in case you're stealing anger or new
here flip off there's a running joke
that I don't have any likes and when in
reality I do have links I know the
secret is out it's just that the air
pollution has cleared out now and you
can finally see them it continues all
the way baby all the way creative and
accurate how it should be I almost did
that I thought you were stealing for a
second if I see a ceiling
you better not you better not decided to
sculpt pizza - he is our animal crossing
characters okay self is worth it
seriously the song is still poppin new I
wasn't like oh my god that looks amazing
the details well done well done
I'm surprised how many people love that
Animal Crossing episode we'll have to
make a new one in the future once we
have something of the show I got married
in an online RPG once
her name was Demon Slayer 64 Demon
Slayer 64 you can't just pretend that I
don't exist in the more Felix okay if
you're stealing gang and you snitch it
better not better not
you better not snitch no more snitching
every time I say don't tell Matt yeah
what are you alright okay guys hear me
out I think I'm on to something
alright another theory okay false legs
holding floor I'm not gonna say if it's
right or wrong but it is 100% accurate
when your wife's boyfriend says it's
bedtime every gamer has been there at
least once and you know it sad floor
getting noises when your wife boyfriend
says he's opening up and only fans
account please save Felix finger oh my
god what is that what excuse me I don't
what was happening it's not that time
again what it must have been like low
pressure or something that's crazy
low - your fan art that will be berry
they knew I well I don't think so
god damn
I like that Hey look I purposely didn't
include the leg cards I like it you know
why because it's so powerful you don't
need them you instantly win right arm of
the simp left art another simp forbidden
left arm sealed by magic whoever breaks
this will know infinite power correct
you are a simple all right I'll take it
I'll take it
Felix Mars Dan Oh Rick No
Demon Slayer you punished you said you
wouldn't do it huh come on everyone's
got married once in an in an RPG
everyone you know I remember I gotta say
it was probably do you mean Slayer most
likely a guy let's get real here
I remember in World of Warcraft that's
when I knew that's when I learned that
sexism was real because I create as soon
as I create a female character and I hit
slash dance everyone is nice to me no
one's ever been nice to me in my entire
life until then hey can I give you gold
like no gosh Felix flora gang
Australians who see Felix hanging from
the ceiling oh my god this confirms they
never even thought about it
Australia is ceiling gang you better be
watching from the ceiling if you're in
the side of the hemisphere
there's so much amazing fare out this
week Jesus Christ it where the beer dad
bro very nice amazing
you got your katana and you got your
mind diamond minecraft pickaxe and your
bro you're ready for anything
those are prosthetics by the way fine
art of Felix and might see an animal
crossing look at that that's so cute I
regret having that outfit now
Fleur gang Tambourine gang Tambourine
gang it's much like subscribe if your
tambourine gang I have to buy a
tambourine now don't a floor gang I knew
it I ordered this it hasn't arrived I
don't want to before a gang anymore
listen every movie Leonardo DiCaprio is
in he's a scent Great Gatsby massive
simply quintessential scent Titanic the
biggest simple all time all right
he could have easily fed on that thing
you know that right but maybe now she
will have sex with me if I die
all right well that's two examples so I
rest my case
Romeo Juliet Matt's Ebsen wait he was an
Akita that's coming out he's producing
it they looked so happy because we're
floor gang smash like subscribers for
floor gang you'll be happy as well yes
that's how that works
my cell looks like she's 10 years
younger than peers but Pierce also looks
like a 13 what the hell what the hell
what the hell she's beautiful though
come on I'm a lucky guy oh you're not a
virgin so you had meat inside of you
okay that's not me truth truth is
anything vegan nothing's vegan if you
think about it
clients are have feelings too everyone
knows this leaked photo of Felix and
Marcia very accurate do not post this
guys I have a reputation to uphold
I'm flora gang I would never stand on
floor never okay we got more Dan
seriously amazing fan art this week so
wholesome so nice I look forward to see
it if you don't mind of course of course
flora gang wait a minute Fleur Fleur
spelled backward is Rolf Rolf literal
again confirm like that five-star Island
nice outfits
lots of emotes Animal Crossing boyfriend
Marcia Felix tampering gang that's right
for life for life I would never I know I
had a lot of running jokes and memes
tambourine is gonna say Sims when the
twitch spot forgets to read their
hundred dollar donation message well I
hope you learned the lesson mr. simpie
seemed like I it looks like he came
straight out of a our YouTube Nintendo
analysis essay so anyway guys my
favorite game
it young me looking at my reflection in
the spoon while doing the haha
reflection funny no you can't laugh at
that student I'm short and my dad is
high teacher Paul not high the dad
you're not supposed to take my
thumbnails stop it that's illegal
hi I'm Emily from oh my god it's her
virgin from non-virgins video if what
can it can't believe you ready to react
is it but offence so oh okay
I'm glad I didn't say anything bad about
her I knew I knew ask me anything I got
all the behind okay all right what do we
got how do you feel when Sean said I
believe you but start istic aliy we get
more money for eliminate you pretty much
knew I was toast
I actually thought Emanuel with the rich
in was Sean as annoying as they made him
out to be he was really playing it up
for the cabins for sure trying to get
more screen time it's not a bad guy some
of us went out to lunch after filming
and they were nice well how about that I
hope they didn't go out with a vegan
girl that sounds that sounds like bad
times
I'm really good Sean been she's been
watching since 2012 epic brofist
tambourine gang right to you that's
tambourine gang right there teacher okay
class we need to sit on the floor for
this activity girls you know boys I've
always been flora gang
people call me out saying I'm fake flora
gang if you watch all my videos it's all
there
the evidence is there look it up it's
consistent you got nothing on me ceiling
gang cringe nothing I watched Phineas
and Ferb if this video gets a million
likes my alt accounts it's like I was
made for this all right what do we got
why don't we got did we hit the number
oh my god I have to watch fitness and
Ferb okay that's funny wait that I only
upload four videos last week I realize
what the hell
my bad gamers wait someone use your fan
art and got up votes no way I'm sorry
shout out to tip bun yet very cool stop
reposting fan hours do dips nice ceiling
gang I know they're out there the
evidence is there the science is there
200 parts let's play incoming liar
well if this video gets I'm not gonna do
that you were ready were you floored gag
after sitting on the floor for a week I
broke my ass imagine everyone that
bought the PewDiePie chair be like
everyone that everyone that bought the
pretty pie chair be like I'm gone that
go back guys I promise I'm gonna go bank
it's okay double clicks to fetch all
nineteen-year-olds I reach that boy what
can I say I'm a I'm a fast learner and
if the auntie not least I just suck it
up like a twitch talk i bought then
three paradise I bought the 399 30pi
chair Laura game listen you cannot be
floor gang unless you have the Peter pie
chair it's the greatest it's a test of
the resilience and self-control because
obviously the 399 chair is the most
comfortable chair of all time so to
still commit to the religion that's
right it's a religion now old flora gang
that really means that you were truly
committed and giving up what is the most
valuable to you bro PewDiePie came to my
Island what when what desert island we
relocated that's not my that's not me
he's serious about turnips I did go to a
fine account because I did sell my turn
it but I don't think it was I made four
million that's right I'm rich I'm a
millionaire in in real life and Animal
Crossing gamers that's what it truly
means to be flora gang if you subscribe
to my 10 step Laura game program you can
be extremely rich to having no legs
having extremely long legs it makes
sense if you truly understand if you
dwell deep in the floor Ganges ism you
would understand this wouldn't exist
this is probably made by fourth the
ceiling gang cringe absolute cringe
small pp downloaded by today I'm here
with the lovely beautiful me see I've
been practicing in the non-stem pre for
year
I'm telling you guys it's consistent you
got nothing on me
sailing game nothing you got nothing I
remember this kid
this is him now feel old yet I saw
people pointing out he look like Peter
Griffin
wife's boyfriend poor kids I mean to be
fair I think we have more memes going on
in the summer now than ever as I at
least related to me the most rarest
thing in the world
the PewDiePie like that's right I do
read comments it's painful but it has to
be done we did it boys Felix not
watching finish and Ferb is not the case
all right all right it might take a
little longer if I have to get through
the copyright of it but I'll I'll see
what I can do all right
a promise is a promise and I've always
kept them another thing that I've been
consistent with you got nothing
Ohio god damn it I did not laugh at that
god damn it
small people delete this Felix start
flora gained 19 year olds I don't want
to sit on you anymore you still want to
sin okay but it's the commitment of this
life we have chosen on the floor all
right I got the merge immediately
respect smooth smooth big peepee energy
right there
Felix are you reading a book yeah dude
it's called the art of seduction later
hey Marcia so I would never ever call
Marzia the B word unless it's buck
masya show something Felix Wow damn
Iringa
tambri gangers a little less exclusive
I'll give you that my sister like how I
judge the game too from people playing
the instrument saying it was the lamest
it's amazing brick floor gang I'm all
about cabinet game you dead I throw my G
feel at you disgusting cabinet gang is
respectable as well if an alliance is
necessary to take out sailing gang I am
willing to cooperate if your if your
cabinet gang let me know Africa now stop
it
this should not be making me laugh up
awful
there it is there it is blower game a
lot much my alright alright I want to
comment on April 29th Pierce channel
won't be nine years old anymore
oh no
[Music]
that's alright I'll just create a new
channel no big deal no big deal say
something nice about the ending haha
tambourine goats tambourine games
no delete this right now he only has one
nether right helmet he only has an ED
the right helmet cringe
Selena Gomez liked then unlike to Justin
Bieber photos on Instagram
keep searching boys we gotta find who
the TF ass this is stuff like an
algorithm li yeah I use big words
suggested to you like right stop it stop
it I don't care I do not care
enemy pewds subnautica terraria
minecraft with marcia if enough people
joins floor gang i'm willing to consider
once i given the heart emoji to random
guy Felix
god damn I'm so today what is happening
pills reads Diogenes pewds one month
later bloggers see who needs
materialistic goods table useless this
is really the floor gang philosophy
right there gamers this is my fishing
bridge join me this is my fishing bridge
the word doc see now let there's a dark
cringe what the blip dark
this is ceiling angling well petition
for Pierce to do and who set that door
okay speaking of a set up tour I got the
computer from Linna so why don't we do
show that big box finally came you know
what's inside I know what how am I gonna
get it I actually got it like a week ago
I just haven't I've been dreading doing
this that's not the thing damn she look
good I know my China
gonna kill mine Mario Kart look that is
insane
[Music]
so this is a computer this feels wrong
it's like we should never meet your
enemies what is this what did you buy me
a car
you bought me a car as well thank you
linens I don't think that's the pose
it's okay I know how to fix computers
I think it will work
you might just explode that's his guts
that's what's inside a creeper in case
anyone was wondering added computer
that's tiny
I don't mean hdmi cable i don't have the
display cable hey guys I need tech
support
hey you came to help thank you I'm not a
hurricane
you know so that cable goes to be
motherboard but the motherboard doesn't
have any power
dude look at I saw this look at that
dent how did it get that in that box
look at that that's awful
dude creeper what did they do to you oh
my god
petition prepares to watch this
masterpiece after finished I've seen it
I haven't finished it but it is great
ceiling gang when Felix calls him I'm
taking them out one by one
no stop sacred it's cringe to say cringe
haha cringe she cheated on me so I keyed
her car Jesus Christ dude
Carson be like nuking the car am right
am i right
when was chairs invented people at the
timeless philosophy gamers it's a
timeless philosophy hey Felix don't
forget you have a shelter boxes they are
kind of like backpacks and you can have
more storage helpful 19 well thank you I
actually completely forgot about that
I'll light it to my minecraft list mom
watch out kids the food is really hot me
and the boys it's that a mother flipping
Jojo spoiler oh god I'm never doing that
again the sauce was so strong that it it
stained the stone what is it called
counterbored or whatever it's called the
stone dark yeah for Rockets left not
enough to get home probably no other
storage and where should they go
extra stacks comes out of nowhere and he
got home super early easy the heck now
give big peepee or I tell that this is
some sealing gang snitching right here
I walk okay through lava and ice and
this is that ceiling stopping stop
snitching stop searching
if spiders work together they could eat
all humans in the air are you serious
dude I woke up with a spider in the bed
today
it was the most shocking thing I've ever
been through it was this size I lift up
the sheet because Edgar's sleep next to
me I know
cringe and I thought it was like a tiny
little egg get the spawned out awful
black demon edgar dark magic
that is so cool I love this style that's
so dope oh my god stop stop oh wait
there's some more shortcuts okay I
thought I did something wrong all right
what else tips that we have all right
what do we get
all right stop doing that when you put
an item into a chest you can simply hold
shift when clicking it okay fair if you
have multiple stacks of an item shift
and double click oh nice oh my god oh my
god
Thank You Adrian I already know all this
of course because I'm a Minecraft
veteran come on don't make me look fat
when you realize I feel like sat on a
pillow making him pillow gang in that
floor
Logan its CGI come on it likes to start
slow because you are not right-clicking
when you are holding oh my god I wish I
knew that when I walked back all the way
Ricardo Marcia Felix Felix
Marcia demons there 64 on stage hearing
your husband scream flora gang every
funny girl accidentally touches my hand
oh there we go
that's flora gang dudes fan art finally
father turntables huh goodbye my fellow
ninety roads F's in the chat bros ex in
the chat another fallen one enjoy the
ceiling cringe happy birthday
cringe amazing Photoshop I don't
understand why it took three times for
this to get in there making names in
English Creole mmm in italiano queenie
felix a dev a vita meant a hospital a
monster a pinch the way the leg what
that flip my head ceiling game this is
how the first time pyramids they went
that completely accurate this is at the
airport though but yeah pretty much
pierce by himself no i'm super edgy and
super hardcore at all times and you can
never touch me cuz I'm flirting and
nothing wrong oh god stop stop it stop
it stop it
Felix needs to stop before it's due
Atlantic we were a gift for McCann ba
island
what can the island will accept thank
you that's the Flying Saucer trick with
my yo-yo every woman in the ten-mile
radius oh you're not virgin have sex
right now what your floor gang
huh prove it you're not flow again seven
the full right now
alright gamers that was it for this
week's subscribe if you're flowe again
smash like of your tambourine gang I see
you guys tomorrow hey Toph
[Music]
[Music]
I wanna have the best of the beefy to
crush the rest and get a fee Jennifer
very sleepy Mary Stefano found on
Shannon sponsee Edgar Maya Tuskegee
sword bill thorry crushing boiling what
you're collecting it makes the lid some
will cross the world looking from dusk
till dawn and I borrow your power cord
my folders down Aquino Terrace but I
gotta commit Burke Kober comma holy
Claudia Rudy roll the King coochie for
estoppel is polish balling what you're
calling
pixal is no one is stronger than me how
many pictures show you from breath down
to crush your polish this is my song as
you notice big bad love will soon be
gone
gusto RC Ted NASA up to Roxy meant for
the Sally
pink slips the greatest game of all time
download it now before to it commercial
I'm spoiling spoiling what you'd call a
king in I'm spoil these fallen spoiling
weren't you calling singing boys boys
falling more Czech Republic
big sur lazy